If you’re in the northern hemisphere, it’s
that time of year when you start to get
cozy, pull those sweaters out of the closet,
sip your pumpkin spice lattes, and stare out
the window, waiting for the leaves to start
turning orange.
Well, over at microcosmos.store we have the
perfect companion for this time of year and
that is our Journey To The Microcosmos sweatshirt.
It’s soft, it’s cozy, and it confirms
to those around you that you are in fact human.
And speaking of that pumpkin spice latte,
we sell a lovely tardigrade mug that is perfect
for your warm beverage of choice, or if you’ve
got 2 billion tardigrades that you need to rehome.
So, check out microcosmos.store, where you
can find our sweatshirt, mug, and even our
very own Microcosmos microscope.
James, our master of microscopes, is always
on the hunt for rare ciliates that live in
areas low in oxygen.
But when he gathers those samples and puts
them under a growth light, his tubes quickly
turn the color of the green sulfur bacteria
that thrive in those anaerobic conditions.
These organisms are not particularly hard
to come by, especially if you know the kinds
of environments that meet their basic needs.
But they can still manage to surprise us,
like in 2005, when scientists reported that
they had found green sulfur bacteria living
in a place that seemed impossible for them
to survive in:
a hydrothermal vent.
Now it doesn’t sound particularly comfortable
to me, but life around a hydrothermal vent
is not impossible.
These structures tend to form in places where
tectonic plates are shifting away from each
other, creating cracks that heated water from
under the crust can then erupt through.
And despite the incredible heat within the
vent and the lack of light around it,
there is life—
an ecosystem built in part on bacteria that
are able to turn chemicals from the vent into food.
These bacteria do not need sunlight to feed
themselves and the organisms that surround them.
But green sulfur bacteria are not like those
chemosynthetic residents that we know to expect
in hydrothermal vents.
Green sulfur bacteria rely entirely on photosynthesis
for their food needs, which means they need light.
Now to understand the secrets behind the green
sulfur bacteria’s deep sea survival, let’s
start by talking about what a green sulfur
bacteria even is.
These bacteria are known more formally as
the family Chlorobiaceae, and their distinguishing
feature is that they abhor oxygen.
To power their photosynthesis, they rely on
reduced sulfur instead, which means that green
sulfur bacteria prefer to live in areas of
water deep enough to favor sulfur
over oxygen but still allow enough light for
the bacteria to create their food.
Most green sulfur species cannot swim, which
is why they’re so still in our footage.
There are a few species that have vacuoles
that can fill or release gas to help them
move up and down the water column.
But overall, they're not really movers.
And you also may have noticed that not all of the
bacteria in our footage is green, and that some of
them are in fact, purple.
At times they’re quite a contrast to the
green sulfur bacteria, not just because of
their color, but because they are able to
swim around.
These purple neighbors do share one common
trait with green sulfur bacteria though:
they also use sulfur to carry out photosynthesis.
And so they are known as, wait for it,
purple sulfur bacteria.
We would call this an uncreative rip-off,
but they were actually described
about a century before
their green counterparts.
As a family, the purple sulfur bacteria are
known as Chromatiaceae, which does feel a
bit more distinct as far as names go.
While the chemical reactions underpinning
their photosynthesis are not identical, purple
and green sulfur bacteria have similar requirements
for where they live to make that photosynthesis happen.
They need light and they need sulfur.
So it isn’t strange to find both organisms
living on our slides together.
But that doesn’t do their proximity enough
justice.
These two bacteria don’t just tend to show
up in the same areas of water.
Green sulfur bacteria like to live
under purple sulfur bacteria, providing sulfur
to their purple upstairs neighbors.
In exchange, the purple sulfur bacteria shield
the green sulfur bacteria from oxygen.
But of course, life isn’t necessarily easy
just because you’ve buried yourself away
from anything vaguely threatening.
The green sulfur bacteria still has to be
able to survive underneath its
Chromatiaceae comforter.
It helps that green sulfur bacteria have a
larger affinity for hydrogen sulfide, ensuring
they still get the chemicals they need to
power their reactions.
But they still need light.
And for that, they rely on a powerful organelle
called the chlorosome.
The chlorosome is unique to green sulfur bacteria,
and its entire purpose is to help the bacteria get light.
It’s the shape of an oval and stuck to the
inside of the plasma membrane.
And inside the chlorosome are around 100,000
of the green sulfur bacteria’s
photosynthetic pigments.
Those pigment are compounds that
aggregate together, creating the largest known
light-harvesting complex in nature.
And this arrangement is different from other familiar
complexes, where pigment compounds are arranged
with proteins, and in much smaller numbers.
In the green sulfur bacteria, the interactions
between these pigments make the bacteria very
efficient at gathering light, and then transferring
that energy to a protein called the Fenna-Matthews
Olson protein, which will help carry the energy
to the areas of the cell that need it for
photosynthesis.
So that even when they’re in the dark, the
green sulfur bacteria can get what they need
to survive.
Of course, sometimes your surroundings are
dark because you’re covered in purple sulfur bacteria.
And sometimes they are dark because you are
in a hydrothermal vent.
And for the scientists behind the 2005 paper
we mentioned at the beginning of the episode,
the chlorosome would end up being a very useful
organelle to know about.
They had gone to the East Pacific Rise, gathering
samples from plumes above the vents.
And in their samples, they found a small,
green, nonmotile phototrophic sulfur bacteria.
It looked a lot like a green sulfur bacteria.
To confirm that it actually was a species
of green sulfur bacteria, they looked for
that Fenna-Matthews Olson protein that transfers
energy from the chlorosome to the photosynthesis
reaction centers.
And there it was:
a protein unique to green sulfur bacteria, a part
of its ingenious methods for harvesting sunlight.
But where was the sunlight?
This is the weird part.
The bacteria weren’t actually harvesting
sunlight.
They were absorbing light from the hydrothermal
vent itself.
The scalding temperatures of the vent produces
thermal radiation, also know as infrared light.
And the green sulfur bacteria’s chlorosomes
were able to make enough use of that light
to carry out photosynthesis.
They weren’t, like thriving under these circumstances.
But they were able to survive, and that is
no small feat.
This actually wasn’t the first time scientists had
found photosynthetic bacteria in hydrothermal
vents, but that previous find appeared to
only be getting extra energy to supplement
its primary chemosynthetic source of food.
This was the first time scientists had found
a species entirely dependent on photosynthesis
at a hydrothermal vents.
A species whose family is thought to survive
only in places with sun, and it had turned
up deep in the ocean thanks to thousands of
pigment molecules that could take in
geothermal radiation.
In their paper, the scientists were quick
to caution that the discovery of green sulfur
bacteria in the hydrothermal vents doesn’t
necessarily tell us much about the evolution
of life in those environments.
The ecosystems in these types of places are
always shifting around, and so we can’t know much
from this one discovery about how the presence
of green sulfur bacteria fits within the
history of the landscape
and the life within it.
But even if it cannot tell us the entirety
of the area’s past, the discovery of green
sulfur bacteria in a hydrothermal vent shows
us just how broad nature can be in applying
the structures it creates, transforming an
ancient process whose requirements we thought
we understood into something entirely different.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
The names on the screen right now, they are
names of our Patreon patrons, people who help
us continue exploring this really marvelous
planet that we all get to inhabit together.
If you want to become one of them, you can
go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
And we very much will appreciate it if you
do, it will allow us to keep making more and
better videos like this one.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram and if you want
to see more from us, there's probably a subscribe
button somewhere nearby.